Hurricane Florence continues to barrel
across the Carolina coast threatening
the area with high winds and major storm
surge Erin Rigsby is one of the storm
chasers tracking Florence in North
Carolina he's covered several major
storms including hurricanes Harvey and
Matthew he ducked into the safety of a
parking garage to join us by phone good
morning good morning how you doing today
well I'm doing all right I'm curious
about how you're doing I heard you
couldn't drive through through
Wilmington is that right what are you
seeing out there now yeah yeah that is
correct I will tell you what this
hurricane went from zero to crazy in no
time you know we were sitting maybe with
30 mile an hour gust and then all of a
sudden we started getting blasted with
80 mile an hour winds we had winds
sustained at 89 hour gusting up to 100
miles an hour we've seen a tremendous
amount of debris falling out of the sky
we've seen large pieces of sheet metal
parts of roof come off we've seen a lot
of flooding especially in the low-lying
areas there's trees down all over the
place and when the eyewall is actually
hitting us it looks like lightning there
were so many power flashes and so
frequent you've covered a few of these
how does this compare this one was
definitely want to you know a lot of the
other hurricanes they were major
hurricanes so his outer fans we were
already getting hurricane-force winds
this one was by far the want it's the
one that went from you know barely
anything just all-out crazy in no time
and the thing that's so similar about
this not necessarily the intensity it's
behaving a lot like hurricane harvey
last year how it's just kind of parking
here slowly moving dumping tremendous
amounts of rain and some of these areas
could see 20 to even 30 inches of rain
by the time it all said and done Erin
I'm gonna ask you a question I'm sure
you're asking quite frequently why do
you do this it's all about passion you
know I've been interested in weather
ever since I was a little kid and you
know I was actually afraid of storms the
longest time but that fear kind of
turned into passion and just you know
witnessing historic events like this it
just you know it's crazy to be a part of
and keeps me going
yeah beyond I was reading my mind Erin
because I was trying to think what goes
into your thought process and how you
can stay so upbeat doing something that
at any moment you can really
your life and I'm very curious about how
you explained this to your mom as you're
walking out the door on one of these
adventures but first start with right
there so and beat about something that
is really clearly so dangerous yeah you
know I've been doing this for seven
years now basically since I had my
license at 16 years old and at first you
know they were you know they still
worried about me at first they were kind
of iffy but I think they know now that
I've been doing this long enough and I
take enough preparations and I always
plan my escape routes when I'm chasing
these things and taking these adventures
and you know it's I always tell them
it's like you know yeah I may be in
danger by putting myself in these kind
of positions for these kind of storms
but I'm also in danger just walking
outside the door every day that's true
and on another note - you also are
bringing valuable information I'm glad
you do it but I worry for you doing my
part to tell the story yeah you give
very valuable information when you're
out there Aaron Rigsby we thank you I'm
glad you have a strategy but please be
careful David nolley thank you so much
you're welcome